hey everyone welcome to this live
session of your daily equation looking
forward to spending about an hour with
you
fielding some of the questions comments
or thoughts that you have and again I
say anything you disagree with you
should feel free to push back and I'll
try to look at the comments to see if
there's any responses to my responses so
this really can be more of a
conversation than you know one way you
ask the questions and I try to give you
the answers I am NOT the sage I know
some things I do not know everything and
I'd love to hear things in which you
perhaps have a perspective that differs
from my own all right I should also
quickly say you know in these sessions
and also in your daily equation we
haven't you know I don't focus on the
virus you we all know why we're here we
all know what's going on in the world
today but I do hope that you guys are
doing alright and that your family your
extended family your friends are I mean
everybody is impacted in one way or
another but I hope that the impact is
something that is something that you
have been able to deal with and maybe if
your daily equation has helped a little
bit with that well you know what could
be more gratifying than that I should
say quickly that on occasion when I miss
the sessions it's you know it's not
because I'm out usually you know playing
baseball or doing something like that
you know my mom is in the hospital she
doesn't have the virus but it is so
complicated anybody that has a loved one
in the hospital right now you know how
how difficult it is you can't visit you
can't go in the patient your loved one
feels completely isolated so I'm dealing
with that as I'm trying to do some other
things at the same time so apologies on
occasion when I miss a session you know
again I don't know how long we're gonna
keep going on with your day of the
equation but at least it's something
that helps me clear my mind once a day
as well all right let's move on then to
the topics of the day and first question
that I see here from Harappa Schad
Ravikumar I think I may have actually
pronounced that correctly maybe
asks what happened to yesterday's video
and actually that question is a good one
it's related to what I just actually was
mentioning a moment ago I was rushing so
fast to get yesterday's video done that
I made a little mistake toward the end
of the video I don't know if you looked
at it too carefully nothing obviously
conceptually was wrong but one
mathematical equation toward the end had
one term that shouldn't have been there
and it sort of made me feel like I
needed to fix it so we took the video
down I'm gonna fix it you know this
weekend or something I know will repost
it with that little change in there so
that's what happened to yesterday's
video very very good question you see
that I'm totally straightforward with
you all right so what other questions do
we have on the more physics front let's
see we have Brian our physical time so
this is from Xin hang Chen says and this
is I think one from Twitter and then
I'll go back to the live YouTube in a
moment our physical time measured with
physical clocks is still absolute i
invariant of reference systems and thus
there is no relativistic space-time in
nature therefore based on relativity all
what the cosmology cosmology Oh Thea
describes is wrong so I'm going to
interpret that question in the following
way which is you know if you have study
relativity if you've gone through the
early episodes of your daily equation
where I was focusing more on relativity
you know that one of the main lessons
that Einstein taught us with relativity
is that there is no preferred reference
frame in the universe in the sense that
if you and I are moving relative to each
other at constant velocity no
acceleration so we don't feel any
feeding up speeding up I should say
speeding up we don't feel and he's
eating up and he's slowing down then we
have the right to claim that we are at
rest and it's the rest of the world
that's rushing by us and any observer in
a frame of reference that has that no
acceleration quality associated with it
can make that claim that they are the
standard of rest against which all
motion from their perspective is
delineated now that then runs headlong
into what seems to be tension with our
cosmological theories and this is what's
in hang is referring to our cosmological
theories talk about things like the
notion of the amount of time since the
Big Bang we never say the amount of time
since the Big Bang on this clock or that
clock or that physical device that may
be moving relative to other clocks when
we speak cosmologically we say it is
13.8 billion years since the Big Bang
period we describe it as if there is a
universal time as if there is a
universal frame of reference with
respect to which that time is measured
so what in the world is going on
relativity taught us that there is no
such universal frame of reference and
the answer is that in the universe our
universe there actually is a special
frame of reference our universe appears
to be homogeneous and isotropic which
means that from an appropriate
perspective if you look out in any
direction the physical qualities you see
are pretty much the same if you measure
physical qualities in any large enough
volume of space regardless of where that
volume happens to be in the universe we
believe that the physical properties
that you measure will be the same that's
what we mean by homogeneity and isotropy
but that quality which is a very very
special physical quality of our universe
is something that only holds true in
particular frames of reference and it's
those frames of reference that we have
in mind when we speak about the age of
the universe or other cosmological
properties so fundamentally there is no
frame of reference that is singled out
over all others but cosmologically
because of the physical environment
within which we live there is a special
frame of reference it doesn't come into
the laws of physics in any special
you can choose any frame that you want
to write down the laws of physics but if
you want your observations to be as
simple and clean and economical as
possible there is a frame of reference
that gives you that economy and that is
any reference frame with respect to
which we describe the cosmological
features of the universe so yes very
good very good question I appreciate
that one read Johnson from the live chat
asks what math classes should physics
students take to become string theorists
question number one that you need to ask
yourself is do you want to be a string
theorist and I don't mean that sort of
tongue-in-cheek I mean you know I'm sort
of identified as a string theorist I do
other things it's not my be-all and
end-all footprint and in science or in
life but it's you need to ask yourself
is the search for the unified theory is
this particular search for unified
theory is putting grabbing and come on
tamiya does that fire you up and yeah if
that fires you up then string theory may
well be the right direction to go
however you need to bear in mind it
could be the case that you work on
string gear for the next 20 30 40 years
you advance the subject hopefully along
with the other string theorists working
around the world but you may still be in
the position that I and other string
theorists are in right now which is we
don't know if this theory is right in
the sense that we don't know if it
describes our physical universe I mean
you know we know when our mathematical
equations are consistent we know when we
haven't made a mistake but we don't know
whether our mathematics is describing
the world until we have observation and
experiment that links the physical
qualities of the world with the
mathematical symbols that we develop on
paper and so if that prospect frightens
you or frustrates you then again I would
think twice about imagining being a
string theorist now putting all that to
the side if you decide to be a string
theorist the math that you need look you
need all the basic stuff you cannot jump
over the basic things mathematically you
have to take differential equations you
have to take all of the math necessary
to do the calculations that for instance
we've done in some of the earlier
episodes multivariable calculus complex
analysis is a pretty useful class to
take as well and then as you keep on
going you need differential geometry if
you are going to focus more on say on
the extra dimensional qualities of space
you need algebraic geometry if you want
to investigate those questions with the
most powerful tools that mathematicians
have developing the topology algebraic
topology differential topology and you
know what I would suggest is take as
many of those courses as you can but
ultimately you should learn the math
that you need for the particular
research problem at hand there's no
better way to learn math then when you
need it to actually solve a research
problem as opposed to a homework set a
problem set problem sets are artificial
but if you're actually on a research
project that needs a body of mathematics
I gotta tell you I've been you know as a
student you know when I was learning I
don't know group representation theory I
do remember this when I was learning
group representation theory that's
something else that you need I needed it
for a research problem and I studied it
with a kind of intensity that I never
had when I was just studying a subject
because it was a course I was taking so
in the end of the day take as many
courses in math as you can but
ultimately your depth of understanding
will really reach its potential when you
need that math to solve research
problems themselves okay the rarest one
asks from the live chat why is gravity
called a force if it needs mass is this
not a reaction not a force well I'm
gonna give two answers to this question
the rarest the first one will deal
direct with your question the second I'm
gonna go in a direction inspired by your
question so look what is what is the
issue so forces are things that can
exert influence but they also respond to
influence you know if you have a magnet
right the magnet is exerting the
magnetic forces
part of the electromagnetic force and my
magnet in my left hand responds to the
magnet in my right hand if I bring them
close to each other that's still the
magnetic force even though the magnet my
left hand is responding to the magnet in
my other hand so that's what forces do
they exert influence they respond to the
environment and that affects the
influence that they subsequently exert
there's another question though that
comes to the fore when gravity is the
force of interest which is Einstein
teaches us and you know you all know
this stuff at one level or another I'm
gonna take on Einsteins ideas I think
starting next week so you know we'll
talk about gravity and then space-time
curvature in connections and metrics and
but with it you know all that sort of
stuff but the bottom line lesson is that
gravity is nothing but the curvature of
space-time and so some people say you
should no longer think about gravity as
a force because objects are simply
moving along the shortest possible
trajectory in the curved space-time
environment that other matter in the
universe in the vicinity creates and so
can we still think about gravity as a
force in the old Newtonian perspective
and my answer to that is you should feel
free to use whatever perspective and
whatever language gives you insight into
a given problem you know if I have the
challenge of plotting the course of a
rocket ship to the moon I'm not using
general relativity and warping and
curbing the space-time I'm gonna use the
simpler description that Isaac Newton
gave us which is you know F equals G m1
m2 over R squared gravity as a force
other problems if I'm looking at orbits
in the vicinity of a black hole I'm
going to use the general relativistic
description and which I'll have
geodesics in a curved space-time
environment I'll then be using the
geometrical as opposed to the force like
language bottom line is use whatever
language is relevant to the kind of
problem that you have at hand and
thinking about gravities of force even
post Einstein is still a perfectly
acceptable and reasonable thing to
you manakish wrong John asks are you
religious well you know not in a
conventional sense we've taken ZUP here
and there in these sessions but I'm
happy to address it and maybe say
something different or flesh out what
I've said before I was born into a
particular religion
you know I'm culturally a member of that
religious tradition
I'm culturally Jewish I do not follow
the religious rituals
I do not adhere to the prescriptions of
this particular religious perspective on
the world
however I've said before and many people
react negatively when I say this but I
speak freely here I hope you don't mind
I do consider myself to be a spiritual
person in the sense that I am deeply
interested in how I and how others try
to make sense within the confines of our
own conscious awareness of why we're
here and and but what we're meant to be
doing with our time or if we can
manufacture some reason for doing things
with our time or if we can gain a deeper
sense of what it means to be a human
being on planet earth in the 21st
century which is a very confusing very
rich but very confusing
anxiety-provoking exciting thrilling I
mean it is something that all of us need
to cope and deal with and and leverage
and make use of in order that we feel
that we have a full life and to me just
understanding the external world which
is my professional preoccupation you
know physics what are we meant to do
make predictions about how that stars
going to move or make predictions for
why the electron has the mass that it
does or why it has the magnetic
properties that it does all that's the
external world then it's a beautiful
focus for us to have within our sights
to answer these questions of object of
reality but that's not the full thing
and again I know that some of you are
familiar I have a book that came out a
couple
to go on it's called until the end of
time and I blend in their explorations
of the external world through the lens
of a physicist trying to understand the
origins of the universe and the origin
of stars and planets and galaxies and
life and consciousness but I also then
turn the lens inward to try to
understand why we humans do what we do
is we try to cope with the world around
us why we tell stories why we invent
myths why we develop religions while we
have creative expression so that book
can give you a much fuller exploration
of these ideas that I can do in this
brief moment of time and I'll also note
for those of you the one of you maybe
who's on I'm actually gonna teach a
summer course at Columbia University on
that book on these very questions so if
that is interesting to you for six weeks
we'll get together you know four hours a
week and talk about these things
it won't be open to the general public
but if you want to sign up for that
course of Columbia I would love to have
you in that class all right so that's my
thoughts on that question let's keep on
going
Salman Suleiman asks hello from
Edinburgh I hope I said that well I've
had practice that you probably like oh
god what a mispronunciation home of the
Higgs can you please explain the Higgs
boson for us yes I'd be happy to do that
so so there was a big puzzle that Peter
Higgs and others too were struggling
with in 1960s which is how do
fundamental particles like electrons the
ones we talk about today or electrons
and quarks and neutrinos where do they
get their mass from and you might say
well it's kind of a strange question
they sort of just have their mass but
but the reason this question was so
pivotal back then and still today
frankly is that when we write down the
mathematical equations that describe
these particles those equations are
highly symmetric which means that those
equations don't change their
mathematical form under particular
rearrangements of the mathematical
that make up the equations and in order
for them to have that symmetry which
turned out to be vital for the
calculations that we do to make sense
for those equations to have that
symmetry that particles need to be
massless and so there is this tension
back in the 60s between the mathematical
description which seemed to be doing a
fantastic job at encapsulating the
patterns evident in particle colliders
and accelerators but those very same
successful looking equations were
suggesting that the particles the
fundamental particles shouldn't have any
mass at all they shouldn't
in essence offer any resistance worried
to push on them so Peter Higgs and
others came along and came up with a
solution and the solution is stunning
it's a solution that people resisted but
the solution is imagine that space
itself is filled with an invisible
substance called the Higgs field now but
you can think of it as a cosmic molasses
it's not a bad image to have my not
perfect by any means but the idea is
that particles fundamentally are
massless but when they encounter the
molasses the molasses exerts a drag
force that if you're pushing on the
particle you've got to overcome to get
the particle to speed up and overcoming
the Higgs molasses this cosmic force is
the origin of the masses of particles so
that's the new idea that Higgs came up
with how do you test this idea well if
you take two particles like two protons
and you slam them together at high
enough speed Berra mind that they are
immersed in the cosmic molasses so when
they collide they can shake the molasses
and when they shake the molasses they
can have a little speck of the molasses
a little drop if you will kind of gets
flicked off and that little drop of the
cosmic molasses that little drop of the
Higgs field is what we called the Higgs
particle or the Higgs boson and
that's the particle that was found at
the Large Hadron Collider back in July
4th of I don't know 2012 or something
and get the years mixed up by now
confirming this idea that Peter Higgs
and others as well put forward some 50
years earlier that's the idea of the
Higgs particle okay so what do we have
here
oh I had a good question it ran away sir
can we interpret the concept of so this
is praia da sir can we interpret the
concept of quantum entanglement to the
emotional feelings that you have for
your mom well IIIi it's a touching
question and let me just take it out of
the personal if you will there been many
there have been many people who over the
years have tried to usurp take over the
ideas of quantum mechanics and use them
to explain or even predict weird
phenomenon on macroscopic scales like
remote sensing you know these people who
claim that they can see things that are
happening far away or people that claim
that there's some kind of extrasensory
perception that links their mind with
other minds and as far as I can tell all
of that is utter nonsense
as far as science seems to indicate
there's no basis for remote sensing
there's no basis for extrasensory
perception at least as it's commonly
described and quantum mechanics
certainly is not the answer to that at
all quantum entanglement is not the
answer quantum entanglement is is a
provocative but very delicate link
between particles that allows them to
correlate the behaviors over arbitrarily
large distances we often describe it in
terms of two particles because that's
when the linkage if you will is
strongest when we have three four or
five particles you can still have
entanglement but it gets so diluted
among the large collection of particles
that the weird properties of quantum
entanglement do something here effects
something over there they themselves get
so diluted that they in essence
disappear so when you're talking about
something with this many particles like
a human brain 10 to the 27 particles the
notion of this whole collection being
entangled with a whole nother collection
is just beyond the bounds of an
thing that makes sense with our
understanding of physics or quantum
mechanics so thanks for the question but
I don't think it is the answer at all
okay Kowalik ecology asks how does
nature know to give every electron the
same mass and its frame your Frank your
questions framed somewhat
anthropomorphic Li as if Nature has some
kind of knowledge base and nature has
some kind of particular ability to
influence the world and nature sits
there and says oh let Ron you've got
five hundred eleven thousand electron
volts as your mass that electrons say
mass and so on we don't I mean I
understand that language and you're
probably just talking poetically of
course that's not how the universe works
the universe has these fundamental
mathematical laws as far as we can tell
or at least we develop these laws to
describe with greatest precision as we
can the properties of the external world
and quantum field theory is our best
understanding of the properties and the
behaviors of particles and according to
quantum field theory there is in essence
an electron field throughout the
universe and when that electron field
gets a little bit excited with a certain
kind of blip a certain kind of energetic
excitation of that field that manifests
as an electron particle and the
mathematical equations that describe
that have a parameter in them that
parameter in essence is the mass of the
electron we measure the electron get
that number stick it into our
mathematical equations but once it's in
our mathematical equations it's one
single number that will apply to any and
all of these particular excitations of
the electron field so it's not so much
that Nature has to know to give each
electron the same mass our understanding
is if quantum field theory is the right
description of the world
that the excitations the the lowest
possible excitation of this field is
what we mean by an electron and the mass
of that excitation is determined by one
number in the mathematical formalism and
that one number because it's not many
numbers that one number is why there is
a uniformity in the mass of every
electron now not everybody is completely
satisfied with that answer and I should
say you know Richard Feynman had an idea
I'm pretty sure Richard Feynman he had
an idea a long time ago as to why every
electron has the same mass imagine it
goes like this he said what if the
universe say early on had the shape like
a doughnut not in terms of its spatial
part but the temporal part imagine that
sort of as an electron moves it can kind
of circle around through time so here it
is at one moment in time it circles
around then it comes back to that moment
in time but now there'll be two
electrons there the original is still
there and now the new one has joined it
because it's done this circumnavigation
around the expanse of time and imagine
this electron goes over and over and
over again around the temporal loop then
you'll have many electrons but all of
them are fundamentally the same electron
just at different moments of time having
circled around this circular temporal
quality of the world so according this
kind of crazy sounding idea the answer
to your question as to why every
electron has the same mass every
electron has the same mass because every
electron would be the same electron I
don't really know if you can make full
sense of this idea but certainly is a
provocative way of addressing the
question but the more traditional answer
that I gave using quantum field theory
is the one that I would really hope you
take away from this discussion okay what
do we have here so I have to have two
answer a question from Ludwig von
Beethoven one of the diehards of your
daily equation so one of your equations
questions is right here
okay Ludwig von Beethoven asks to what
extent is it valuable to try and study
at a prestigious university abroad even
if they basically teach you the same
thing
yeah I'd say it's obviously not a
technical question but it certainly is a
good question of life if you will
because many of you who are watching
this from other countries and want to be
say a physicist you face that question
do you go to school in your own country
you go abroad you know to go to the
United States you go to England you go
to some of the other centres where
certain kinds of science has been the
center of attention for a number of
decades and in the end of the day you
can succeed regardless of where you go
to school in the end the beauty of the
field of physics is you're judged on
your papers you are not judged on where
you went
you're not judged on who your advisor
was you're judged on the quality of your
research papers and regardless of where
you're from you can write great papers
now having said that there are some who
would say what I just said was a little
bit naive and it's slightly naivety in
the following sense if you want to get a
job teaching for instance in country X
and I'm gonna take X to be the United
States just because I'm here and I'm
familiar with it
if you want to get a job teaching in the
United States it is useful to build up a
network of people that know you in the
United States and that can be achieved
more easily for many people by being in
the United States by being a student in
the United States by being a
postdoctoral fellow in the United States
so from that perspective it can aid you
in going forward but lid where you're
completely right when it comes to
learning the subject if you have good
teachers regardless of where they are
regardless of whether it's a prestigious
place or not if you have a good teacher
and you work hard of course
you can make great strides and of course
you can be successful so it's ultimately
a personal choice but in the end of the
day if you're just focusing upon can you
learn the subject really well yeah you
can learn the subject really well
anywhere at all
all right Caitlyn from North Carolina
asks a good Bell's Theorem lecture Thank
You Caitlin I appreciate that but I
don't understand why the ratio is
greater than five ninths definitely
proves Einstein's hypothesis of locality
I'd actually say I've disproved
Einstein's hypothesis of locality so so
here's how it goes
Caitlin and for those of you who didn't
watch the Bell's Theorem discussion of a
few days ago check it out I think you'll
enjoy it so as you know Caitlin Einstein
was very disturbed by the spooky action
at a distance he was disturbed by the
seemingly non-local qualities of quantum
mechanics do something here and it
effects something over here that
nonlocality was like to him
reprehensible so he's trying to come up
with his colleagues with an explanation
that would not need this kind of non
locality and so in an effort to get rid
of nonlocality he imagined that the
widely separated particles always have
whatever property is revealed by
measurement so it's not as though a
measurement causes one to snap to
attention and causes the other distant
one to snap to attention that would be
spooky he says if this is the result of
your measurement then this particle was
always up and this one was always down
so he says quantum mechanics describes
the world as if particles can be in a
fuzzy mixture of here and there or up
and down but that he says is a failure
of quantum mechanics not some true
feature of reality and many people said
well that's an interesting idea
Einstein but how would you ever prove it
and the little example I gave him the in
the discussion in that episode was you
know where I to tell you that my hair is
Inc except when you're looking how would
you ever prove or disprove it because in
order to access access the color of my
hair you've got to look at me you've got
observed me but I'm telling you when you
observe me you change the outcome so it
seems to be one of those statements that
are untestable until 1964 john bell
comes up with an experiment and as i
described in the episode if you involve
these more refined detectors have three
settings and you imagine that these
particles don't just have definite
features along one axis but along three
possible axes then what I did in the
episode was I showed if the idea that
the particles have definite features and
there's no nonlocality because you don't
need nonlocality if you have these
definite features if they do have
definite features John bells analysis
shows there is an experimental
prediction that that assumption makes
and as I showed you the experimental
prediction is that if you do a whole
bunch of measurements of the particle
spins among all sorts of random axes
more than five nines of the time they
should be pointing in opposite
directions so again the logic is if
Einstein is right and if there are these
definite features and therefore there is
no
action at a distance no spookiness then
the data had better show that they look
like this or like this more than five
ninths of the time the data does not
show that the data shows that there like
this and like this 50% of the time five
nine six fifty five percent so the data
rules out the prediction that comes from
Einstein's vision that particles have
definite features and you don't need
this kind of nonlocality so when the
data contradicted the prediction that
emerges from einstein's idea you realize
that there's something wrong with
Einstein's idea
Einstein's idea again is there isn't any
non locality you only have definite
features therefore what's wrong the
assumption that there is no non locality
therefore there is non locality what you
do here affects something over there
that's the argument I also gave some
caveats as to potential loopholes I
won't go through them here but Caitlin
that's the answer to your question as to
why the ratio being greater than five
nines which is contradicting the
experiments disproves the vision that
Einstein was trying to put forward okay
what do we have here
all right pack D asks can you explain
more how quantum phenomenon would apply
to macroscopic objects like people and
why that is not observable yeah again
you know quantum mechanics does apply to
macroscopic objects it applies to me it
applies to you it applies to Swiss
cheese it applies to everything because
everything is made up of particles which
themselves are governed by quantum
mechanics so if you have little
ingredients that are governed by quantum
mechanics as you put more and more of
them together you're still governed by
quantum mechanics but what we also
understand well and in one of the videos
where I described how you go from
quantum to classical mechanics in one of
the earlier episodes I described this in
a little mathematical detail but one
thing that we understand quite well is
when you have a lot of stuff a lot of
particles a lot of mass it's not that
quantum mechanics is no longer relevant
it's that the most startling qualities
of quantum mechanics get highly
suppressed so what are these startling
qualities of quantum mechanics they are
if you're measuring the position of a
particle at one moment you could find it
here and next moment you could find it
there and so for the next moment you
might find it in principle near the moon
that's weird right
particles jumping around they don't seem
to follow the nice kind of smooth
Newtonian trajectories that professor
Isaac taught us about back in the late
1600s particles can also tunnel through
barriers I haven't spoken about that
maybe I should maybe I should do a
little thing on quantum tunneling yeah I
think I may do that right so you know
particles can encounter a barrier that
the classical physics says the particle
can't penetrate but when you do the
experiment every so often the particle
does penetrate the barrier weird but we
never see people walking through
barriers and reappearing on the other
side not because it can't happen it can
happen in principle
but for a whole huge collection of
particles each of which is unlikely to
pass through a barrier for them all to
pass through the barrier the odds are
enormous Lee against that happening so
if the odds are small for a single
particle they become spectacularly small
for a whole large collection of
particles and that's why for macroscopic
beings quantum mechanics still applies
but you don't see the deeply weird
features in the macro world because
they're suppressed not that they're not
they're not that that can happen is just
that they happen far less frequently and
by far less I mean spectacularly less
often that is the issue okay what do we
got here Goran Koehler says it's not
live anymore yeah it's life I just
answered your is it not live anymore
so yes I'm completely here and live in
the flesh as far as I know okay vesemir
says would you say your new book falls
more into the field of philosophy rather
than physics and I understand the
question vesemir my own view is that
there's a somewhat artificial division
between physics and philosophy between
science and frankly other subjects in
the world
so yes according to those arbitrary
artificial divisions what I discuss in
until the end of time is sort of in the
borderland between physics and
philosophy but I don't really consider
the way I deal with these issues in the
book to benefit from thinking about the
sideload nature of the academic world
the academic world has generally found
in university settings the questions
that I take up in the book are honest
powerful deep questions of physics
entropy second law of thermodynamics the
hour of time but I show how those
questions in physics can give us insight
into questions that we don't always talk
about in physics like issues of free
will or ease of consciousness or issues
trying to make sense of the world beyond
just making predictions for this or that
quality to emerge from this or that
experiment so yes I would say it does
branch between physics and philosophy
but I would encourage you not to look at
that divide as something fundamental
it's what we have erected in order to
organize our understanding of the kinds
of education that students can get in
universities but that's not really a
good way I think of feeling the kinds of
insights and knowledge that we humans
have developed thinking of it more
holistically I frankly find much more
interesting and useful okay so see cat
from cat family says is it possible for
you to go faster than the speed of light
would you go back in time and um as far
as we know it is not possible for a
material object to speed up to and then
exceed the speed of light roughly
speaking as I described in the episode
on relativistic mass as a body that has
intrinsic heft rest mass if it is
accelerated to faster and faster speed
its relativistic mass gets more and more
which means you have to exert it in ever
it's powerful push to make it go faster
still and as that body approaches the
speed of light it's a relativistic mass
source to infinity which means you need
an infinite push to get that body to
speed up to and to reach and then to
exceed the speed of light and since
there's no such thing as an infinite
force material objects can't cross the
speed of light barrier that does leave
open the possibility though that there
might be an entity that was born
traveling faster than the speed of light
always travels faster than the speed of
light never travels less than the speed
of light so that material object often
called the tachyon would always be on
the other side of the speed of light
barrier and it would never cross just as
we can
cross 2 greater than the speed of light
it would never cross 2 traveling less
than the speed of light as a tachyon
loses energy therefore it can't slow
down right if it goes slower than the
speed of light as a tack down loses
energy it speeds up everything's kind of
reversed on the other side now your
question can had to do with what this
would imply for the nature of time and
yeah there's some weird temporal
implications if I had a tachyon gun
right and I fired it at you then
according to some observers moving by us
in the appropriate manner they would
describe the sequence of events not as
my pulling the trigger the tachyon
traveling from the gun and hitting you
they would say the tachyon hit you
before I pulled the trigger the temporal
order of what we would think of causal
events can be come up ended if there are
these particles that travel faster than
the speed of light so most of us think
that it's not possible to travel fast in
the speed of light but it's just to say
that no one has completely ruled out
although most people do not believe in
this possibility of these tachyons ok
what else do we have here
oh hi from Turkey
so Baris gegen from Turkey if we
consider Lorentz contraction now don't
go away
lunge contraction and time dilation is
it possible to say a photon would
experience the whole universe in an
instant at a point and there's I would
say poetically you can say that and what
I mean by poetically well in your
question you talked about photon
experience and you do put quotes around
experience because you and I and
everyone else know well
that photons don't experience things
they don't have conscious awareness you
might think that's secondary to the
question but it's actually important to
the question because when I say poetic I
mean that in some sense a photon would
experience all moments at once because
our famous gamma factor 1 over the
square root of 1 minus V squared over C
squared that goes to infinity when V
goes to C and V is C for a photon so
there's this infinite time dilation
factor infinite Lorentz contraction
factors for things seem to be infinitely
compressed and time to be infinitely
slowed down but the problem is if you
then want to interpret that as an
experience that's where you run into
trouble photons don't experience things
and therefore the very notion of what
it's like to be a photon is putting a
conscious being in a frame of reference
that a conscious being will never attain
because conscious beings as far as you
know require material structure a
material structure cannot travel at the
speed of light so yes is the answer to
your question sort of but the quotes
around the word experience that you
wrote down they're actually quite
essential to not over interpreting what
this means take it with a grain of salt
that a photon would experience all space
at one moment in time ok so what else do
we have here have
111 asked what do you think about
controlled psychedelic experiences what
today tell us about our mind its
connectivity with the universe and so on
well I don't know Aven off if you're
really interested you could re you could
listen to a podcast I did a couple
months ago with Joe Rogan you know Joe
Rogan kind of cool guy enjoyed that
interview a lot I think it was number I
can't remember the number but any find
it Joe Rogan and I had a conversation
and I spoke a little bit about
psychedelic experiences there I don't
want to spend a lot of time on and hear
it beyond saying that the mind is
complex and rich and refined
organization of particulate matter which
allows it to do spectacular things and
among the things that are quite stunning
about the mind is if you introduce just
a few distinct chemicals from what the
mind usually has coursing through its
structure the experience the subjective
experience can be radically different
what does that teach us well some people
say it doesn't teach us anything at all
to me at least helps me gain an
intuition for the fact that particles
can think and particles can feel if
they're arranged in the right way and if
you shift the arrangement a little bit
they think and they feel differently and
to have an experience like that
to me at least gives a more visceral
understanding of how it is that the
minds experiences are dictated by the
particles that are moving through the
brain change the particles a little bit
and the experience changes dramatically
and I'm not advocating anybody to
undertake these kinds of experiences
that can be dangerous but in answer to
your question that is my own personal
view and again feel free to look at the
Joe Rogan podcast if you want to have a
little further discussion of that
Timm Harnick from belgium do you think
math is invented or discovered actually
addressed that a little bit in the very
first episode of your daily equation
which now seems like it was years ago
but I guess it was just about a month
ago or something like that so you can
see a more complete discussion there but
very briefly I've had both of those
views throughout my life there are times
when I thought math is out there and all
we do is discover it I've had periods
when I think that math is something that
we human beings invent to encapsulate
the patterns that we encounter in our
excursions into the world around us if
you were to ask me what's my perspective
right now it's the latter I for a number
of years seem to settle down on this
view it's almost as though as I said I
think in that episode when the
mathematical research is going really
well it sometimes does feel that all
you're doing is chipping away the
obscuring layers and the math is there
for the taking and perhaps when the math
isn't going as well you don't feel it
way but this is not a view that's born
out of going through sort of difficult
mathematical times I really have come to
the view that there are many languages
that we human beings invent in order to
be able to live more fully in the world
and and live more effectively in the
world of course we invent natural
languages that allow us to communicate
so we can coordinate our actions so that
we can better survive not always but we
also invent the language of mathematics
that gives us a very precise way of
articulating certain kinds of patterns
in the world rising and setting of the
Sun or the falling of objects or water
as it's going down a stream and so my
view for a while has been it's that it's
simply the case that math is one more
language very particular very precise
language but just one more language that
we humans invent in order to fully
articulate the patterns that we
encounter in the world around us
okay how we doing on time Oh time flies
I wonder if I should see if there's
anything over on the other feed here
I'll stick to the live one it's right in
front of me
Rob Vandenberg asks do Q&A sessions like
this inspire you that they do I can't
say that they actually literally
inspired the next research project but
engaging with you guys and and and and
and thinkers and and folks who just want
to know about the world to me is an
exciting thing you know it's exciting
that people want to know about things
you can get the impression looking out
at certain things that happen in the
world and come to the conclusion that
people don't want to think deeply
people don't want to explore people
don't trust science people are not
interested in the insights that can come
out of this kind of closed experiment
observation and mathematical theorizing
and to have a group of individuals that
come together for these hour-long
sessions and clearly have all sorts of
interesting and exciting questions that
they want to know the answer to yes it
does inspire me in that way absolutely
for sure okay so what do we have here so
th asks as an infinitely expanding
universe is energy density goes to zero
does that mean it's total energy will
decrease as T goes to infinity energy
when it comes to the entire universe is
a fairly subtle idea in fact the whole
idea of energy conservation is one that
you have to be very careful about
depending upon the precise shape of the
universe as you're noting if space was
on infinitely far let's say it's flat
and if there's a certain amount of
energy density in each volume of space
and the total energy would be infinite
so what exactly does it mean even to
have a conservation law
associated with a number that's infinite
so rather than talking about total
energy which is somewhat hard to talk
about generally in cosmology we tend to
focus on a region of space and we ask
ourselves is the case that the energy in
that region changes only because there's
some energy flowing out or some energy
coming in and that kind of local notion
of energy conservation is right there in
Einstein's equations of the general
theory of relativity the one thing I
would say that's a little bit subtle is
gravitational energy is a quantity that
you recall from Newtonian physics is
negative right the potential energy is
minus GM over R right and that's
negative in and it goes to 0 when masses
are infinitely far away from each other
but it has this negative value as you
bring a mass in from infinity so in some
sense gravity provides an infinite
energy well that other things in the
universe can mine in order to have
positive energy at the expense of ever
more negative gravitational energy and
that we think may be the answer to how
for instance during inflationary
expansion which I've not discussed in
these episodes but in an inflationary
expansion the energy density actually
stays the same as space expands density
stays this bet is the same a space
expand so there's more energy it seems
where does that energy come from one
explanation is that it comes from the
negative energy that the gravitational
field acquires and so it's sort of a
trade-off negative gravitational energy
against the positive energy filling
space from the inflationary expansion
van Ron asks when will your recent talk
with Alan Alda be online um I believe
that Alan is going to turn that into a
podcast in his own podcast which I think
it's called clear and vivid
so if wherever you get podcasts wherever
you get your podcast if you look up Alan
all those clear and vivid I believe it
should be coming out or you know it also
do
follow me on Twitter if you don't
already at be green and I will
definitely post that conversation with
Alan when it becomes public it was it
was a it was a it was a it was a really
good conversation we have focus on some
pretty thorny issues many of which that
I discuss in my book until the end of
time and I think I think you will
absolutely enjoy that okay
Archer says is a positive or dr. Greene
to answer all questions at once
especially mine well if it wasn't for
the fact that the universe had something
called time everything would be
happening all at once but it does have
time and we have a limited amount left
so because of that I will not try to
answer all questions at the same moment
sanyukta asks can you explain Hawking
radiation let me look at the clock yeah
I can explain it so there there are many
ways of explaining it in non
mathematical terms none of them
obviously are perfect and night razor
asks about my my muddy water as I'm
talking and so so here's the way to talk
about Hawking radiation that I think is
quite reasonable if you have a black
hole right and in fact you know I have a
black hole sort of in front of me right
can bring this see this is my microphone
right here so this is kind of like a
black hole right here the surface of
this here so right at the edge of a
black hole you have the traditional
property of quantum mechanics that
particles pop into and out of existence
this is the quantum fulmination that
happen in any region of space regardless
of where that space might be something
special happens when particles and
antiparticles pop into existence near
the edge of a black hole over here if
they're far away from black hole
particle/anti-particle pop into
existence they find each other they
annihilate you go from the vacuum to
this protocol pair back to the vacuum
near the edge of a black hole however
when an anti particle and a particle
appear sometimes one of those particles
falls into the black hole that means the
other does
have a partner with which to annihilate
what does it do it just streams away
from the black hole so in essence at the
edge of the black hole
particle/anti-particle appear one can
fall in the other races away now that
can happen at every single point along
the edge of the black hole and therefore
you have particles streaming away from
the event horizon of the black hole
those particles streaming away
constitute the radiation that Stephen
Hawking was the first person to
recognize back in 1974 and this is
believed to be a very general feature
that happens in any theory that blends
quantum mechanics in the general theory
of relativity so we think that quantum
mechanics and general relativity are
both part of the physical world and
therefore we think that Hawking
radiation is a quality of black holes
all right time for a couple more what do
we got here
so campus cryptid
I guess in response to that answer so we
finally have our conversation going
campus cryptid says what the universe
creates particles from nothing what I
hope that was right inflection Campus
scripted and and yeah that's that's one
of the weird qualities of quantum
mechanics when you take into account the
quantum mechanical uncertainty principle
which tells you in the example that I
did in one of these episodes that you
can't nail down the position and the
speed of a particle simultaneously well
if you think about its speed is
associated to energy and therefore it's
telling you that energy can be uncertain
and when you're a little bit more
precise about this you learn that it's a
trade-off between the amount of energy
and the time which it takes you to
measure that amount of energy it's a
it's an E and T trade-off just like the
usual position and momentum one is a P
and X trade-off and so if the energy
itself can be uncertain over short
timescales the shorter the time scale
the bigger the uncertainty in the energy
and that means over very short
timescales
the energy can actually blossom up and
that energy that just sort of appears
even in empty space can manifest itself
in the form of particles now those
particles can't live long is the usual
way that we say this all this can be
made somewhat more precise so this loose
language is obviously loose but when the
particle and antiparticle pair appear
they're living on borrowed energy if you
will so they can't live on the barred
energy for a very long period of time
because they have the delta T Delta e
uncertainty principle so pretty quickly
the particle antiparticle find each
other annihilate and they give back the
energy borrowed in their own creation so
those kind of processes but this excuse
me those kind of processes are happening
all the time
they're happening right now right in
front of my eyes it's just that the time
skills are so short and the energies are
such that they particles quickly
annihilate that on average you don't see
any of that happening at all you can
measure these processes they have a
measurable impact on certain particle
properties that we can measure with
great precision so we have no doubt that
these kind of properties of the quantum
vacuum are correct and when the quantum
vacuum is near the edge of a black hole
in answer to the previous question that
inspired your response the weirdness is
that one member of the particle pair can
fall into the black hole leaving the
partner to race off into outer space and
that's the Hawking radiation all right
well I think we're sort of done but let
me see if I can I'll finish up with a
dang Joss is question could to be
multiple dimensions of time like there
are four space and um you should have
stopped a lies ahead man I'm starting to
have trouble talking but um is it
possible yes it is possible but I should
emphasize that having many dimensions of
space is something that we know how to
cope with right we live in a world that
has at least three dimensions of space
left-right back-forth up-down so when
the theory for instance like string
theory comes along and requires more
dimensions of space than that it's not
really a big conceptual load is a big
conceptual it's not an insanely big
conceptual leap because we're already
familiar with having a plurality of
spatial dimensions three so to go to
four is like just adding one more it's
definitely a leap but it's not as big a
leap as it would be to go from one
dimension of space to to going from a
singular to a plural that's a big leap
for time we're familiar with one time
dimension so go from one time dimension
to two time dimensions that is a big
leap how do you make sense of the second
time dimension are there are there two
notions
of time that exists in in conjunction
with or in parallel with each other you
know is one aligned with psychological
time is the other somehow a different
temporal quality of the world so these
are the notions they have to struggle
with when you want to make a theory that
involves multiple time dimensions but
people have tried and there's been some
degree of success friend of mine who
have not seen in a very long time
it's like bars wrote a number of papers
you know maybe it's a decade or two ago
exploring - time dimension theories and
he as far as I recall was able to go
pretty far and making sense of those
theories I don't think that anybody
takes them seriously there's no evidence
for a second time dimension but it's at
least interesting to see that you can
make mathematical sense of a theory that
has more than one dimension of time all
right speaking of time well what the
hell I'll just keep going a little bit
that kind of gave me a little boost of
energy so if there's something here that
catches my eye before I sign off someone
hit me with like you know the kind of
question that I just could not possibly
resist all right Aven oov asks me this
question what do you think about the
creation of consciousness in the paper
of consciousness and microtubules of
Roger Penrose and Hameroff Stuart
Hameroff what do I think about that
honest truth is I've not read the paper
that care I have looked at the paper
I've not read it extremely carefully and
I say that you know I find it
interesting that there are these
processes that take place in the brain
that there may be some suggestion that
there's something to do between them and
conscious awareness but the bottom line
is there's nothing that I've ever seen
in in the Penrose Hameroff
ideas which addresses the really deep
question of consciousness which is how
is it possible
any kind of physical process acting out
on physical particles whether it's
microtubules quantum entanglement
any of those processes yield the
sensation of inner awareness I mean I
mean if you've never thought about this
deeply after we finished today you
should just sort of sit down and ponder
this particles electrons quarks
neutrinos protons neutrons electrons
they don't have we don't think although
some would disagree they seemingly don't
have any kind of conscious
self-awareness so how is it that by
putting two of them together or three of
them together or twenty of them together
or ten to the twenty seven of them
together how do you somehow yield this
property that seems completely disjoint
from the qualities of the particles
themselves how is it that you and I have
inner films inner voices inner lights
that are on right now where in the world
does that come from and nothing even if
Penrose and Hameroff are correct in
terms of the role of these processes and
the microtubules I don't think that it
addresses this question at all and from
that point of view therefore you know
it's interesting to think about but I
don't think it gives us the insight that
we are searching for so so Cuccia an
answer to that says how about a higher
level of biological experience and and
yes look it is the case that there can
be so-called emergent phenomena emergent
properties right some people would say
hey you know water has this quality
called wetness but h2o molecules they
don't seem to have this quality called
wetness what would it mean for a single
h2o molecule to be wet it's like just a
thing you know to HSN a know in a
particular shape there's no witness
there so the folks taking this line of
thought would say wetness is an emerging
property when you have a lot of h2o
molecule similarly conscious awareness
is in a
Mergent property when you have a lot of
particles arranged in the right pattern
and to some extent I have to say I
believe that I still find it deeply
puzzling I do however agree with the
viewpoint that there's nothing more
necessary to have conscious awareness
beyond particles and physical laws so I
am in that camp at the same time I still
find it mysterious that we can have
these inner sensations and I suspect at
some point maybe the first artificially
intelligent being that really has
conscious self-awareness how would we
know that I don't know but if there
really is a being that has conscious
self-awareness and convinces us that has
emotions and feelings and it's just a
box with chips wired up in the right way
I think at that point the mystery of
consciousness would slowly dissipate and
we'd be like yeah consciousness yeah
it's like wetness of water it's just the
kind of thing that happens when
particles are arranged in the right way
all right someone just asked me if I was
going to explain string theory someday
and I'm happy to explain string theory
you know it's a funny series this series
your daily equation because I like the
idea that we're talking a little bit of
math in each of the episodes because I'm
used to either doing my math in my
research papers that go to esoteric
journals or when I talk to a general
audience I'm talking totally without
mathematics you know the famous dictum
of Stephen Hawking every equation and
the book cuts down the readership I
factor to write so so there's a sense
that you don't put equations into the
discussions you have with the general
public so I like that this one is a
little bit different at the same time it
does sort of constrain the types of
things that I speak about I mean if I
was gonna try to explain strength here
and actually include some of the
mathematics you know it's it gets kind
of involved pretty quickly so you know
maybe I'll do a string theory episode
and just at the very end throw at you a
few of the equations the string theories
that I keep in line with
my own directive to have a little bit
the math in these things but that's what
makes it a little bit hard to jump right
in to certain subjects where the
mathematics becomes so so involved so
quickly as M Nayeem s have you met Ashok
Sen I have met Ashok Sen one of the
great Indian physicist one of the great
string theorists a brilliant individual
and if you happen to know him do tell
him I said hello and hope that he is
doing well all right Zhang Jing Li says
what is the significance or the status
of string theory when there doesn't seem
to be any experiment that can confirm or
verify the ideas and yeah very quickly
you're right Jung Yong Li sorry I'm
trying yong yong li the big problem with
strength there is exactly the one that
you're talking about we've been working
at the theory since the late 1960s we've
made incredible strides strides that are
well beyond what I would have thought we
would have been able to achieve by the
year 2020 if you ask me as a graduate
student in the 1980s will we be able to
have potentially non perturbative
formulation of string theory I don't
think so if it asked me you know will we
gain insight into nature space and time
the fundamental ingredients perhaps that
make up space and time will we have
anything to say about that question by
2020 I would say mmm I don't think so
and yet we have gotten to those places
the flip side though which is what the
question is about if you ask me in the
1980s will we have experimental
observations experimental data that we
can link up to string theory bye dear
2020 I'd like yeah I think so yeah I
would have said I think we'll find the
supersymmetric particles that string
theory requires it's called super string
theory the super is supersymmetry we
haven't found those particles I would
have hoped that we define even evidence
for extra dimensions the last couple
decades a possibility that we find
missing energy signatures at the Large
Hadron Collider to give evidence for
more than three dimensions of space but
none of this has yet turned out to bear
fruit so it's not that string theory
somehow failed which is what some people
say it's just that linking it up to
experiment and observation has proven
even more challenging than many of us
thought decades ago so what's the
current status the theory is alive and
well and being developed by many people
around the world
the mathematical insights are
significant the techniques that have
emerged from string theory for dealing
with a whole variety of different fields
some in condensed matter theory some in
issues of black hole physics I mean
there's been a lot of fantastically deep
developments but your question is right
we do not have the observational
evidence or the experimental data to
show that this theory is a theory of our
world one hopes that that will change
but one also doesn't have a crystal ball
to determine the timescales necessary
for that to happen my one footnote to
that question is you'd look at any other
quantum mechanical theory of gravity
loop quantum gravity dynamical
triangulations whatever they face the
same problem when you put gravity and
quantum mechanics together you are
exploring nature in extreme realms of
very short distances and very high
energy those realms are very difficult
to access experimentally that's what the
problem is it's not a string theory
problem it is a problem of quantum
gravity amanda asked as a science
educator what do you think is the main
technique that brings out the most
interest curiosity and joy of learning
from students well yeah it's a good it's
a very good question and I guess I'd
quickly say that I can answer in the
negative first I know what does not
bring out the interest curiosity and joy
and that's the kind of education which
is highly assessment focused when the
kids are learning in order to avoid
getting a bad grade on an exam when the
way that you get a good grade on an exam
is by just quickly
memorizing a whole variety of qualities
whether it's this or that formula or
this or that part of the cell or this or
that chemical reaction you spit it back
on the exam you do well you leave it
behind and on and on you go and science
was just this thing that you had to get
through and the sad truth is for many
students but not all because there are
some great science teachers around the
world but for many students that they
tell me is their experience so I am NOT
soft on the details of science kids need
to learn the details science can't just
be some coletek subject but you need the
poetry to go along with teaching the
details you need kids to recognize that
with these details they can learn about
the origin of the universe and the
nature of black holes and weird
qualities of space and time I mean when
you can have a parallel focus on the
very things that make us professionals
excited about a subject if you can get
that across to kids then learning the
details is something that has a purpose
to it as opposed to the purpose being
and getting a good grade on the
assessment which I find tragic when it
goes in that direction and I'm speaking
from personal perspective I see this
with my kids you know my kids just want
for the most part to get through it and
it's very sad to me and I do my best to
inspire them on occasion I succeed and
when that happens it's gratifying but
for the most part their education is
about assessment to say this students
getting an A this students getting an A+
this ones getting and being I'm like oh
my god are you kidding me that's not
what education should be about and I
don't have the answer I know that for
education and we need to assess in order
that the colleges need to know which
students they want to take so they can
assess them again and why do they assess
them because in the job market we want
to know which students should get the
better I mean on and on it goes isn't
there another
there has to be another way and frankly
for the health of the world there there
better be another way okay so so I don't
know I don't know
people still hanging out I don't keep it
going for a little bit if if you guys
don't mind I'll keep answering a few
questions all right all right all right
what do we have
Leslie Turner says professional people
are boring
uh yeah I'm not I'm not going to touch
that one exactly some are I guess so
[Music]
Oh Amanda wrote back good conversation
thank you I agree I'll try and implement
another way on my own students as well
Amanda that that would be great every
step matters every person matters and as
I said I don't know the answer kids have
to take you know standardized tests they
have to be able to have learned the
material necessary so it's this tension
between the way the world is set up and
the way you can imagine the world could
possibly be paddy Kumar is gravity
fundamental or is it emergent is it an
emergent force and I I don't know the
answer but it is a profoundly
interesting question prog deep in the
last few years a number of scientists I
mean this actually goes even further
back back Ted Jacobson for Linda and so
on have wondered about whether it might
be the case that gravity is actually not
one of the fundamental forces of the
world gravity might emerge from
properties of space and time when
properly understood and that sense the
charge of a fundamental theory would not
be to explain gravity per se is to
explain the deeper structure out of
which gravity emerges that can sound
really abstract let me just give you one
little example which I think is useful
to bear in mind you and I we all know
what temperature means right we know
what it means to be hot or to be cold
but there's a deeper explanation at the
level of particles something's hot when
the
molecules are moving really quickly
right when I burn my mouth on my muddy
Earl Grey tea water it's because the
molecules are moving so quickly that
bang into my tongue in my mouth and they
sear it when it's cold the molecules are
moving slowly so temperature is an
emergent idea that emerges from this
more fundamental description of the
velocity of particles it might be the
case that gravity is like that gravity
might emerge from the more fundamental
description of the ingredients of
reality and therefore it is not a self
fundamental idea rather it is simply a
consequence of the particles behaving in
the manner dictated by the deep
equations that we are still trying to
find so uh sour syrup asks do you think
that we may be able to test quantum
superposition principle someday and my
answer to your Sarab is yes we do test
it I mean if you go back to the episode
that I had I forget which one it was but
I did the double slit experiment maybe
it was in the debris wavelength episode
early on and in that example the
traditional and famous double slit
experiment of quantum mechanics you've
got two openings and therefore your
probability wave and the quantum
description is going through both of
those openings and it's superposing
the wave from each opening is
superposing with the wave from the other
and that superposition is what dictates
the interference pattern bright dark
bright dark bright dark on the detector
screen and we test that we do the
experiment and we get that interference
pattern we get the result of the
superposition of the probability waves
emerging from each opening so I would
say yes is the answer for sure and
indeed it has already happened and it
happens in fact all the time ok what
else do we have here
muscle builder says how can it seem that
the universe and reality is smooth and
continuous if in reality it ticks with
the Planck time and it's sort of
pixelated on the Planck length and
muscle builder I should tell you first
it could be that space and time are
smooth we don't know but you are right
in saying that our deep descriptions are
pointing toward the possibility that
space and time are not smooth that space
and time may themselves be quantized
they may themselves be made up of
ingredients that themselves do not look
smooth and continuous but rather are
chunked out on very small scale so your
question is a good one how could the
universe appear smooth and continuous
if fundamentally it's not and and and
and you know the answer to that question
actually because right now you're
looking at me on a screen if you were to
look really closely at that screen you
would see the little pixels but as you
move away from the screen it all looks
smooth and continuous at least if you
have a good monitor like my monitor is a
reasonably good one right here it looks
perfectly smooth and continuous and yet
I know that it's just made up of little
pixels so it's just to say that on the
scales that we have access to with
today's technology tomorrow's technology
- we can't probe the Planck length we
can't probe the Planck time Planck
length as I did in the Planck length
episode that's about 10 to the minus 33
centimeters we can't probe even with the
Large Hadron Collider smaller than
whatever ten to the minus I don't know
18 centimeters 10 to minus 20 senators
um like that it's many orders of
magnitude to course to see if there is a
pixelated nature to space similarly for
time we can't probe down to 10 to the
minus 43 10 to minus 44 seconds it's
just too small our probing of the
universe is so coarse
by comparison that the world can look
smooth both in space and time even
though it may not actually be smooth at
all so that's the way the world can fool
us into thinking
there are qualities out there when deep
down those qualities are not part of the
fundamental description of reality so
what else do we have here
Christopher asked what is the difference
between M theory and string theory in
some sense there is no difference string
theory was the name that we gave to this
purported unified theory developed
between 1968 and 1995 let's say because
it was clear from the mathematical
description that the fundamental
ingredient was a little filament of
energy that could be with open ends or
in a loop and it looked like a little
piece of string so called its string
theory something happened in 1995 that
kind of blew all of our minds
Edie Witten you've probably heard of him
he is the Einstein of our age he's at
the Institute for Advanced Study which
is where Einstein himself was Ed Witten
gave a lecture at University of Southern
California that was completely
unexpected and in that lecture we began
to learn that string theory has other
ingredients that are not string like
that can be membrane like of various
dimensions membrane starts with an M M
for M theory that is one of the possible
interpretations of the M&M theory and
therefore we learn that string theory is
really part of a larger theoretical
edifice that includes these other
entities not just vibrating filaments
also vibrating flying carpets or
vibrating globules and so forth and so M
theory is in some sense the more refined
description of string theory so they're
all one and the same even though they
emerged in some sense at different times
and it for the names are somewhat
different because of that all right so
what else do we have here any other
questions that people have yes it's
rolling by we just try to stop it
alie asks do you see any Universal time
or would you like to define time tied to
biological time sure and and I don't see
any notion of universal time
fundamentally written two laws of
physics but as I mentioned earlier in
the relevant frame of reference that
allows our description of cosmology to
be as simple as possible making use of
the symmetry of the universe then there
is a cosmic time it's the time that we
quote when we talk about the universe
being 13.8 billion years old but that's
not fundamental that's just an
environmental fact and so it's a quality
of time in this environment that we call
the universe
but I wouldn't say that it's written in
to the fundamental laws of physics
itself all right another one from Sarab
asks how did life evolve from nonliving
matter answer I have no idea I have no
idea
you know that that is you know a deep
question my guess and I believe it's the
guess that most people would now put
forward is that life is not like turning
on a light bulb it's not as though you
have no life you turn on the switch and
you'll have life
there's rather a continuum between what
we would typically call inanimate
nonliving matter to living matter and
that continuum is along an axis if you
will of ever greater biological
organization or complexity of some sort
so when you have molecules arranged in
rather coarse configurations you can get
things like cell membranes you can get
some of the possibility of molecules
being able to replicate themselves and
so forth but you wouldn't call it a
living system yet but as this collection
of molecules is acted upon by natural
selection
natural selection works even before life
emerges natural selection is just the
capacity of particles that
learn to replicate those that replicate
faster more efficiently more stable e
they're gonna draw in more of the raw
material environment and thereby
dominate the molecular demographics and
as they mutate they can make even better
molecules at reproducing and some of
those molecules will find themselves
inside a fatty lipid membrane and they
find that they're able to carry the
processes even better and over time the
refinement that happens just gives us a
continuum from nonliving molecules to
what we would call living configurations
of molecules that I think is the the
best answer so I don't think they were
ever going to come to a point where we
say and there's the final ingredient
that gives us life that's vitalism
that's an idea that was put forward a
long time ago that nobody really takes
seriously any longer I think most people
believe that particles and laws is all
that you need in order for life to have
a chance of emerging you do not need
some other ingredient beyond that okay
what time is it 428 Mable do two more
minutes just call this a 90 minute
session well you tell me when you want
me to wrap it up you folks out there who
are asking the questions because I'm
happy to go a little bit longer today
all right Daniel asks how do positrons
move backward in time as proposed in a
Fineman diagram and look this is a
really is a really good question I mean
Fryman had creative and unusual ways of
interpreting physical law and one of the
ones that really strikes the imagination
is he said look you can think of an
electron as a particle that travels in
the ordinary direction of time going
forward a positron an anti particle in
the diagrams that he wrote down and in
the equations that those diagrams
represent he said you can think about
that positron as if it's a particle
traveling backward in time I consider
that to be an interesting and useful
mnemonic if you will for writing down
Fineman diagrams I certainly don't think
about positrons is travelling backward
in time yeah I understand the
mathematical equation I see it up there
in the exponent you know either the
minus IET versus e to the IET you know
so so I totally get it and I totally get
the diagrammatic representation of these
things but I think I think in the end it
makes the interpretation of the quantum
mechanics seem more mysterious than it
really is
you can really think about particles is
traveling forward in time even though
phiman did give us this creative way of
thinking about it i I don't find it
particularly useful especially in these
kinds of conversations because then you
get into the issue of well if there's
time travel in the microscopic lies in
their time travel into the past in the
macroscopic and I think all of that to
red-herring just coming from a kind of
misuse of the idea that phiman was
putting forward okay so Corey O'Connell
asks when physicists say our knowledge
of physics break down at the singularity
of a black hole what precisely breaks
down thank you so much even there's a
little picture there Thank You Cora
tornado picture and and the answer is
this quarry so we make use of Einstein's
general theory of relativity in order to
understand the nature of space and time
in the
vicinity of a black hole and I'm gonna
talk about that mathematics I believe
next week it comes from a refinement or
really I should say an application of
Einstein's equations by Karl
Schwarzschild back in 1917 that's where
the notion of a black hole emerges in
Einstein's theory and here's what you
find when you look at the equation so
again I'll write this equation down next
week you find that if you try to apply
that equation right at the center of a
black hole at the coordinate value R
equals zero you find that the curvature
of space-time blows up it goes to
infinity
in fact the curvature goes like 1
divided by R to the sixth power and as
you know if you have one divided by zero
you put that into a calculator
it says era similarly if you put 1
divided by R to the 6 then you said R
equal to 0 you get 1 divided by 0 to the
6 which is 1 divided by 0 you get era
that's what we mean by a singularity the
mathematics blows up in our face it goes
to infinity it's something that we have
difficulty making sense of so most of us
interpret that singularity to mean that
we need a more refined mathematical
description of what happens in that
region of space-time indeed
Einstein's equations do not take into
account quantum mechanics at all so the
hope is that if what quantum mechanics
and general relativity together then we
won't have a singularity when we apply
that combined mathematics near the
center of a black hole and that's the
hope it's been partly realized in other
examples we're still not quite sure
about what happens at the center of a
black hole but that's what we mean by a
singularity I should say just as an
addendum to them sometimes people use
the word singularity as this mysterious
word I know Ray Kurzweil likes to use it
that
the singularity is near I think that was
a point when computer power was meant to
outstrip the power of the human brain
and so forth but singularity to a
physicist really means one and only one
thing it means we don't know what the
hell is going on when we see a
singularity
it means the math has broken down the
math doesn't make any sense the
equations are nonsensical like 1/0 at
that point we say we need better
mathematics
so that's Cori the answer to what we
mean by the singularity in a black hole
okay okay anything left are we done Oh
any any new results Kevin asks from LIGO
since 2015 oh yes Kevin maybe they
haven't made the headlines as much but
Kevin you're noting that in 2015 we
received the first gravitational wave
signal two colliding black holes that
was a spectacular moment confirming an
idea that emerges from Einstein's theory
that had been kicking around for a
hundred years and we finally captured
one of these ripples in the fabric of
space-time but since then there been
many other gravitational waves that LIGO
has detected collisions between neutron
stars is a notable example that has
given us new insight into how certain
kinds of elements are synthesized and I
don't know I think it could be well over
50 events now have been detected by the
LIGO gravitational wave Observatory so
yes it's alive and well and making
progress so it's a very exciting field
of physics research Sun yolk to ask do
you think that the Big Bang was an
accident
it's hard for me to interpret what that
means whose accident would it be could
it be that you know some advanced
civilization was playing around with
their universe creating equipment and
accidentally produced this universe I
guess but now we sort of venture into
the land of silliness right it's hard
for us to make sense of what that would
really mean I don't
ascribe any overarching intelligence to
the cosmos doesn't mean that there can't
be we discussed that earlier but I don't
find any need for it therefore the whole
notion of what an accident would be in
the absence of a guiding intelligence it
leaves me with a sense of I don't know
what I'm talking about so I hope that
gives you some sense to why I have not
much to say on that at all
Andreas has 53 exclamation points wow I
had no idea
referring to the LIGO detection yeah and
that's why you come to these live Q&A s
andreas to be wowed no I think many of
you are familiar with that but I'm happy
to fill you in on what's been happening
in the last few months or last two years
sooo Bargh TV ask wait don't run away
let me scroll you back what do you think
could be the next big discovery in
science well look I'm extremely excited
about the gravitational wave
observations that we just mentioned I'm
extremely excited about work that's
happening in other fields there's so
much wonderful research on the brain and
consciousness and memory and you know if
I was starting out again as a young man
with with with dark dark black hair I
think I would be tempted to go into the
area of neuroscience or even
computational neuroscience you know
really trying to model the processes in
the brain using our detailed insights
into machine the machine learning I
think artificial intelligence in general
artificial intelligence I think it's
just such an exciting kind of endeavor
that's going on
so so all that's great if you ask me in
my own field what I think the next big
discovery will be or what will spark the
next big revolution I think it is when
we finally gain insight into the true
nature of space-time you know is
space-time emergent we spoke about
emergent gravity earlier space-time and
it's curvature that's what gravity is so
we're talking about emergent space-time
as well if we could really understand
the molecules or the atoms of space and
time then yeah I think that could easily
spark the next revolution our Pitt asks
is the universe infinite answer I don't
know nobody does one possibility is that
space does go on forever and that's all
there is to it bear in mind that if
space is infinite today it would have
been infinite near the Big Bang as you
want the cosmic film further and further
back in time infinity if you got 1/2
infinity winding halfway back it's not
exactly linear in that way for all but
you got the idea
half of infinity is still infinity 1/4
of infinity is still infinity so when we
talk about the Big Bang as being this
little tiny speck in an infinite
universe that's kind of the wrong image
the Big Bang would have happened on an
infinite expanse everything that we know
in our observable universe which is a
finite distance from us would have
emerged from a little speck on that
infinite expanse
but the totality of reality would not
have been this little tiny dot that we
always picture with the Big Bang the
totality of reality in the infinite
version would have been infinitely big
even at the Big Bang itself do we know
that that's the extent of space we don't
it could be finite in which case the
little speck image would be a fine image
because if something's finite and you
wanted to film back it gets smaller and
smaller and when finite things get
smaller they truly get smaller infinite
things when they get smaller don't so
that's the difference between the two um
what else
[Music]
inflation I saw an inflation question
could inflation this is mr. s but
inflation could be at separate spaces at
an infinite space that's exactly right
mr. s so so you could imagine that there
are infinitely many big bangs even our
Big Bang could be one of that grand
collection and it is the eruption of
this region of space but there could be
eruptions that happened
a different and far flung locations
within this wider cosmological landscape
so yes it could be that the picture of
the grandest view of the cosmos is
completely different from the one that
we entertain when we think about our
single universe that could be a small
part of an astoundingly much larger
reality if the Big Bang that we know to
yield at our universe yield at universe
upon universe upon universe far out on
the cosmic expanse okay let's see
si monster asks hey professor a simple
question what are you working on at the
moment are you working on a theory or
are you busy with the world science
festival well look I do split my time
between research and bringing projects
of various sorts out to the public on
the on the physics front you know I've
been working for a while I'm trying to
understand these ideas of a multiverse
if we can identify a notion of
probability on the multiverse to say
which universes will be likely or not if
we can develop a notion of stability on
the multiverse to figure out what
universes would hang around for a long
time and those universes that would
quickly disintegrate that led me into
some work having to do with mining
quantum entanglement from the vacuum
which is something I worked on with one
of my students in recent times and I
also have an interest on trying to
explain the dark energy with quantum
mechanical processes perhaps with the
Casimir Energy so I have a variety of
research projects of that sort but
you're right the world science festival
was meant to go live in New York at the
end of May obviously we're not going to
do that but we are developing programs
that number one we are distributing now
this actually is sort of one of them but
you know more straightforward and more
familiar world science festival offer
where we have a variety scientists and
conversation about cutting-edge ideas we
are going to start releasing those new
programs sometime probably in June and
throughout the summer so that is another
thing that I'm involved with but if
you're asking I'll tell you a few other
cool things that I'm doing I have this
piece that I did with the composer
Philip Glass about a boy going to the
edge of a black hole it's a symphonic
piece it's a stage with an orchestra and
a film and an arat it's called Icarus at
the edge of time I'm working on a sequel
to that right now so that's kind of fun
I'm also working on a live stage show on
quantum mechanics we have a live stage
show you may know on the general theory
of relativity called light falls it was
on PBS last May you're not supposed to
be able to see it unless you pay for it
but you go to you search for it online
and someone has a bootleg copy up and
take a look love to hear your comments
so that's a version of the kind of
presentation I'm talking about but we're
building a new one on quantum mechanics
so kind of a range of things both in the
physics research and in the science for
the public the blending of science and
art and as I mentioned before I'm also
teaching a course this summer on my book
at Columbia NE Columbia students or you
don't even have to be a Columbia student
I do think that make you pay though but
if you want to interact with me on some
of the big ideas of the origin of the
universe and life and mind and galaxies
and what it will be like in the far
future will be meeting twice a week
Tuesdays and Thursdays from 6 p.m. to 9
p.m. Eastern Standard Time as part of
this course called origins and meaning
at Columbia and you guys want to go
check that out love to have you in that
class anyway that's gives you some
flavor of the things that I'm working on
in the moment as seif asks does the
fabric of space-time really exist or
isn't an idea that Einstein used to
visualize gravity and if it does exist
what's it made of
can it bending can space-time tear and
look that's a deep question as Heath
I believe that Einstein thought that
space-time was a real thing
people debate this and philosophers have
written you know thousands of pages on
the reality or not of space-time in the
same I'm Stein Ian sense here's where I
come down on it space-time is enough of
a something to define what we mean by
accelerated motion
you see if the universe was completely
empty no matter nothing in there but
space-time itself according to the
equations of general relativity if you
were to take two rocks say and have a
rope between them and spin them around
according to the equations of general
relativity those rocks would pull taut
as you would think they would based on
your experience in the everyday world
but if there's nothing else in the
universe what are these rocks spinning
with respect to in fact can you even
define a notion of spinning if there
aren't any benchmarks physical
benchmarks for motion and according to
the general theory of relativity you can
talk about the acceleration that these
rocks are experiencing what are they
accelerating with respect to space-time
itself so space-time itself seems to be
enough of us something to allow us to
define accelerated motion
now given that can space-time tear and
you're talking to somebody for whom the
tearing of space-time is especially
close to his heart you know one of the
insights that I was fortunate to be
involved with is to show that within
string theory the fabric of space can
rip in fact we did this in two stages
our our first insight was that
space-time could rip in very mild waves
that are called flop transitions that's
a technical mathematical term however
weird and colloquial it sounds we then
subsequently show that far more drastic
rips in the fabric of space so called
khana fold points or conical transitions
were also allowed by string theory so
it's pretty much accepted that if string
theory is correct that there is a no
of the tearing of the fabric of space
and again it's hard to imagine what
woman mean by the tearing of the fabric
of space if the fabric of space were not
actually a real thing so an answer to a
question I would say yes it is enough of
a real thing to talk about acceleration
to talk about ripping okay what else we
got here um any other questions or
should I well you know for I'm gonna go
for a few more minutes and then wrap it
up okay so
felis super it says if you have two
entangled particles far apart and you
observe one of them then can you still
observe interference pattern in a double
slit experiment on the other particle
and and it's hard for me to answer that
question in full generality but let me
let me say it this way so when you talk
about the double slit experiment the
part of that experiment that really
matters to this question is the ability
of the superposed waves from the two
different possibilities to blend and mel
to interfere and yield the bright dark
bright dark pattern so the critical
thing here is can we retain that level
of quantum weirdness even after a
measurement and the answer to that is
largely no when we measure a particle
the impact of that interaction is to get
rid of all of the weird quantum
possibilities force them to ante up is
the language that I'd like to use and
decide on a single definite outcome and
when you have single definite outcomes
you're suppressing your basic getting
rid of the quantum weirdness so in
entanglement you measure this particle
and it causes this one to snap out of
the haze you're now in one of the single
definite States you have eliminated all
of the quantum weirdness associated with
superposition the possibility that a
particle could be a multiple states at
the same time and in that sense you have
gone away from the possibility of being
able to expose superposition exposed
quantum weirdness by virtue of your
interaction by virtue of that
measurement so the quick answer would be
no pink lady asks oh and pink lady
apples those in fact those are my
favorite apples pink lady good did
Einstein ever believe in a multiverse or
a fourth dimension
well four multiverse I don't think so
you know like I don't really know
precisely the history of the multiverse
certainly the quantum mechanical
multiverse was introduced by Hugh
Everett in 1957 Einstein died in 1955 so
he probably didn't think about that at
all for the fourth dimension that was an
idea that emerged from Einstein's
teacher Hermann Minkowski who may you
may recall was the teacher who thought
I'm Stein wasn't going to achieve very
much in his life he said that Einstein
was a lazy dog and yet Einstein showed
Hermann Minkowski to be wrong but anyway
so in her Mankowski learned about
Einsteins insights into special
relativity he was the one who introduced
this idea of time as a fourth dimension
Einstein resisted this idea at first I
think he felt it was too formal too
mathematical ultimately though he
realized the power of thinking about
space and time in a uniform language and
that uniform language is indeed the
language of the fourth dimension that
Minkowski introduced so yes Einstein
definitely did believe in time as a
fourth dimension uh what else do we have
here
somebody asked why'd lecture 24 is not
visible I answered that earlier so you
can look back at the beginning the very
very beginning of this live session
[Music]
let's see
Cambridge Cambridge breeze Brian what is
your opinion on Steven Wolfram's claim
about his unified theory I don't know I
think I addressed this a little bit in
the last live session but very briefly
look Steve is a brilliant person huge
impact on the world of science and
mathematics with Mathematica anything
that he says is worth thinking about
worth looking into I haven't had time
yet to do so I do intend to try to get a
better understanding of what he has in
mind my gut feeling is it's not the
unify it's not the answer to everything
simply because almost every proposal is
every put forward is not the answer so
throwing it into that bin leads me to
have skepticism when new ideas are
proposing big revolutions in our
thinking but when it comes to Steve
Wolfram maybe it is a big revolution so
all just to say I need to look into it
further before I can pass any sensible
judgment on it whatsoever and he's
actually broadcasting the discussions
that they're having and trying to push
this program for it I believe it's made
publicly available so if you want to
listen in to people trying to develop
Wolfram's idea you can do that and
that's kind of very different very cool
very exciting so you look it up online
and and maybe you guys can report back
next time on if I haven't had a chance
to look at it by then if if there's
anything that you got excited about
listening to that all right all right
what is your favorite sci-fi movie of
all time maybe that's a good good nice
light question to finish up with
although I have to tell you part of me
wonders how long would you go with this
session would we would we all just sort
of peter out or would be like be able to
go like 10
um so so what is my favorite sci-fi
movie of all time well I loved the
original Planet of the Apes
you know Charlton Heston on the sand you
know looking at the half sunken Statue
of Liberty
wow that's spectacular
I love contact you know I thought it
just had a really good feel for the
wonders of space and and and the wonders
of time and had a had a strong emotional
component to it I know that there other
sci-fi movies that I really loved and I
know that I'm they're gonna all come
flooding to me maybe you guys can tell
me your favorite movie in the chat right
here and as they scroll by perhaps I can
be remembered would be reminded of the
ones that really mattered to me but
those are the ones that that come to
mind so Dan Cooper says 10 hours sounds
good all right one person is uh happy to
do that
contact bomb deals like that film Oh
2001 thank you Eric W yeah 2001 a great
film but I have to tell you and you're
gonna perhaps consider me a Philistine
for saying this I tried to watch it a
couple years ago with my kids but maybe
because my kids were there that was part
of it but it was so incredibly slow in
the beginning maybe we've all become
accustomed to things having to move fast
and and the velocity of the story that
it was really hard to hold my kids
attention and I have to say I began to
wander a little bit too in the very
beginning of 2001
yeah interstellar good film you know you
know and and close to my heart - because
interstellar there's a beautiful scene
in which characters go near the edge of
a black hole they spend time there time
slows down near the edge of a black hole
so they come back and everybody else is
aged a lot and as it turns out that's
actually the operative element in a
story that I wrote back in 2008 and it
was this one Icarus at the edge of time
that I mentioned before about the boy
going to a black hole so that is the
operative element in that
particular story so yeah I think it's
really cool when Einstein's general
theory of relativity is brought into a
narrative setting absolutely other uh
Monty Python yeah so meaning of life
part one love it yeah can run low the
run you know I like Run Lola Run somehow
it didn't really stick with me as well
there it is
but rang thank you the matrix how could
I leave out the matrix now the matrix
speaks to all these issues about what
consciousness is the degree to which you
can trust your conscious experiences to
what degree reality could be completely
different from what you think it is
based on your everyday experiences so in
fact in the course that I'm teaching we
wants the matrix because even if you've
seen it before
it just brings right to the fore these
important philosophical issues about
what science can ultimately tell us
about the true nature of reality because
science is ultimately processed through
the human brain so everything that we
know about the world is colored by our
ability to think through and to
experience reality and therefore there
is this intermediary between us and the
true nature of the world and the matrix
shows you how that intermediary can
yield a deeply misleading view on what
reality actually is oh yes a bi choco
thank you inception I loved inception I
think inception is again you know it's
one of these films that plays with
perception plays with understanding you
know and and look how can you fault a
film that uses a spinning top and
perhaps the the procession of the top to
be used to distinguish between worlds
that are real and worlds that are not
yes so so some really great examples you
guys give as the scroll is going by here
Paola asks would you do a series on
explaining the science and movies I'd
love it if you would do and yeah you
know my friend Neil Tyson
likes to take that particular arena on
and he does it with a wonderful degree
of entertainment value and so on
occasion you know I do weigh in on the
science in movies and I think you know
there could be a good series in there in
fact you know we've been chit-chatting
with some television producers and that
is one of the ideas that we've been
kicking around just a little bit the
most important thing to bear in mind
though is I think you know when you
watch a film or at least let me speak
person when I watch a film I like to
just let it wash over me I love it when
if there is science I don't need to
think about the signs I need to evaluate
it I just like to be transported into a
different world when a film fails for me
with their science in it we're either
it's like so blatantly ridiculous that I
just dismiss it or if the film breaks
its own inner rules
I don't mind bending the rules of
physics but don't bend them at will bend
them let me know the kind of rules that
are gonna govern the world that you're
studying and don't change it at the last
minute because I hate that because that
just feels laziness on the part of the
writer or the director of the producer
so but yes I think that would be a fun
yes d hhhh ace has a beautiful mind yes
I loved a beautiful mind you know how
how wonderful to have an inner glimpse
of the kinds of experiences that a brain
can have if it's not working in the
manner that's more familiar to us it
goes back to our question earlier on
psychedelics in consciousness here's a
case where it's not psychedelics per se
it's a brain whose functioning is
somewhat different from the functioning
of most of our brains and that allowed
that brain to have experiences that are
are spectacularly unfamiliar and I
thought that film did a wonderful job of
giving us a sensation of what it was
like to be inside that mind and what it
was like to be inside a mind that is at
one and the same time troubled but also
deeply insightful so yeah I think that's
a that is absolutely a beautiful a
beautiful example okay is the speed of
light Mohammed asks the limit in the
multiverse and how do I answer that
question um so so I would say that the
answer is yes in the following sense did
multiverse theories that are really
worth thinking about are the multiverses
in which the distinct universes emerged
from some underlying mathematical law I
mean anybody can say hey what if there
are other universes and maybe those
universes are filled with Swiss cheese
whatever anybody can do that that's not
interesting what's interesting is when
you have a mathematical theory that is
motivated by understanding things in the
world around you and that mathematical
theory then predicts the possibility of
other universes and in the mathematical
theories that we study of that sort the
speed of light is an intrinsic quality
of the mathematics a general theory of
relativity special theory of relativity
all in there so in that sense the
qualities of light and its speed is not
something that you change willy-nilly
from universe to universe it's something
that's dictated by the underlying
mathematics now having said that
environmental differences in different
universes can affect the kinds of speeds
or kinds of qualities that inhabitants
in those worlds would measure so even in
eso so yes so there is a flexibility in
that the environments can look quite
different the force of gravity can have
radically different strains the
qualities of electromagnetism can differ
and so for the electromagnet ultimately
to do with light so in that sense there
is a flexibility from universe to
universe but I don't want you to think
that there is a things that are just
changed at will it emerges from some
underlying fixed mathematical structure
that can yield universes that have
different environmental details those
environmental details can affect the
things that we measure
alright guys what do you what do you
think quickly tell me you want to ask a
few more or do you want to take a break
until til next time
like if they love it will answer this
question as you're answering them so ash
aunt asks if quantum mechanics makes the
universe non-deterministic then how are
you going to figure out the grand
unified theory and I love that question
because it's one that I get a lot and it
allows me to emphasize what quantum
mechanics is not quantum mechanics is
not a theory that somehow imbues the
universe with some kind of deep in
determinism the equations of quantum
mechanics which we studied in one of the
episodes in Schrodinger's equation those
equations are deterministic the math of
quantum mechanics is just as
deterministic as the math of classical
mechanics the only difference is whereas
the math of classical mechanics predicts
definite outcomes for observation and
experiment the deterministic math of
quantum mechanics only predicts the
probabilities of getting one or another
outcome but predicts those probabilities
with deterministic mathematics so
quantum mechanics is deeply
deterministic but what it determines our
possibilities as opposed to definite
outcomes and therefore it's not like
quantum mechanics makes everything
uncertain or prevents you from making
progress not at all
in fact quantum mechanics yields the
most precise predictions that we have
ever had we can make calculations with
quantum mechanics and do experiments and
find that they match to the tenth
decimal place after the decimal point
you call that
kind of undetermined ISM or some kind of
uncertainty uh uh
that's pretty damn certain and that's
really what quantum mechanics gives you
so you really need to avoid hearing the
words Heisenberg uncertainty or quantum
indeterminacy and employing them in a
way that they are not meant to be used
and I hope that that clarifies that very
important point all right Danny long as
why did the universe immediately clap I
think Donnie long means why didn't the
universe immediate collapse into a black
hole
following inflation and and this is an
interesting question because if a black
hole is when you have a lot of matter in
a region of space and that region of
space is affected and in some sense
collapse in on itself well you know near
the Big Bang wasn't there a lot of
matter why didn't the whole universe
collapse in on itself two answers that
number one the black hole solution of
Einstein's general relativity assumes
that the matter you're talking about is
within a pre-existing spatial
environment when we talk about the Big
Bang there is no pre-existing spatial
environment the Big Bang creates the
spatial environment and therefore our
intuition from black holes in ordinary
space needs to be updated when we are
trying to think about matter in a
context like the Big Bang second we
believe that the early universe was very
homogeneous highly similar indistinct
locations and so it didn't to create the
centers the gravitational centers around
which matter would fall in to create
black holes so as inflation is happening
it propels everything outward it propels
space and time themselves to stretch and
in the aftermath of that you have this
nice largely homogeneous realm in which
things
are moving outward and so the
homogeneity which requires you not to
have these gravitational centers which
will suck in the matter surrounding as
well as the outward swelling itself
counters the tendency for things to fall
together in to come P objects' like
black holes there was an interesting one
I just saw and it just went by anon as
was your opinion about the Rigveda I I
can't give you an opinion on that for
that you need to ask my brother maybe
you've got me confused with him he is an
expert on these particular texts and he
actually just taught a course on the Rig
Veda I believe at Hofstra University in
New York online so look him up ask him
tell him I sent you all right someone
just asked if I could say a few words
about the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics I don't know where
that question went but yeah look I just
mentioned that the math of quantum
mechanics is deterministic but that it
determines probabilities so if the math
determines that the probability of an
electron to be here is 30% and here to
be 50% here to be 20% the natural
question is when you undertake a
measurement why do you only find it at
one place or another what happens to the
other possibilities that emerge from the
mathematics of quantum mechanics and in
many worlds interpretation from Hugh
Everett says well what here's what
happens if there are three possible
locations for the location of the
electron and you measure its position
you find it here the court in Hugh
Everett there are actually versions of
you that find it here and here as well
those possibilities do not go away but
rather they take place in a completely
separate reality a reality that in some
sense the math of quantum mechanics
separates off from the reality which you
found the Allah
Tron here so each of these possible
outcomes is realized in its own separate
world and that's why it's called the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics so it's a highly controversial
subject my friend
Sean Carroll recently wrote a book he is
a dedicated mini-world er if you will I
am not as dedicated to this approach I
think there are mathematical details
that still need to be ironed out before
we can take this idea seriously but yeah
you know it is one viable approach to
trying to make sense of the reality
which the quantum mathematics is leading
us to not everybody does so eric w says
shout out to the eels and that's right
so cue everett sun i forgot his first
name Oh Doran maybe Erika can tell me
but Hugh Everett son formed a group
called the eels and in fact participated
in a very interesting film that I can't
remember the name of the film got him
becoming forgetful in my old age here
and and there's a very interesting film
in which cue Everett's son was
reflecting on his father and his
father's role at least in part on
developing this many-worlds approach to
quantum mechanics let's see what else we
have here uh Naveen asks about my
opinion on white holes and white holes
are basically time reversed versions of
black holes so since the laws of physics
are time reversal invariant if they
allow black holes to form you to assume
that white holes were not everything's
falling in but everything's spewing out
would be allowed to many people think
that there are principles that forbid
the creation of white holes I am of the
opinion that white hos likely do not
exist but I should say that there are
people who think about these ideas and
have different opinions and have thought
about it more than I have so I can't
really give you a
the answer on white holes but no I do
not think I do not think that white
holes are real someone asks and it went
by Oh William Selby asked what are your
thoughts on loop quantum gravity and the
William my view is that I'm glad that
there are people developing alternative
approaches to blending quantum mechanics
and general relativity is a very
important subject you know we we we have
been struggling to realize the dream of
a unified theory that would put together
the laws of the big and laws of the
small into one coherent mathematical
framework and to put all your eggs into
one theoretical basket namely that of
string theory would not be a good
strategy for the species right so I'm
glad that there are other approaches to
quantum gravity that are being developed
I think that string theory has the
better chance of being the right theory
for many reasons the mathematical
structure of the theory feels more
convincing to me the way it deals with
quantum mechanics feels more convincing
to me and and a variety of other
technical details that maybe I'll spell
out and one of these your daily equation
episodes and maybe I should do one on
loop quantum gravity like I said in one
of the earlier episodes so many
equations so little time I don't know
what I'll get to but um you know so my
thought about loop quantum gravity it
could be the right theory I'm glad
people are developing it maybe we'll
find connections between it and string
theory before all the dust is settled so
so I'm a proponent of the varieties of
approaches that we take to solve deep
challenges and Luke on gravity is an
absolutely viable approach and I'm glad
that people are working on it
I don't think however that it's the
right approach where I'd be working on
that myself okay man what do we it still
is still rolling along here
okay okay what else how does it Priok
has it feel to be vegan I don't know I
feel I think I've been weak
ever since it turned vegan 25 years ago
so I'm not sure I don't know how to
answer that question
Debra dr. Brian from Mohammed how was it
sufficient for just one difference
between matter and antimatter to create
everything that's referring to a little
video that we had a quick year daily
equation where I noted that if you had a
billion in one particles of anti it's
called a matter billion one particles of
matter for every billion particles an
antimatter then when the matter name to
matter find each other and collide one
particle of matter would be left over
the question is how is that enough well
it's an enough to create all the stuff
in the universe which is not just one
particle well when you look at the
cosmological evolution of matter from
just after the Big Bang until today you
can calculate how much stuff would be
say in our observable universe and the
amount of stuff that you need in order
to have the stars and galaxies
ultimately form is such that you only
need about one part to billion of all of
the matter particles that could have
been created so I wasn't trying to say
there's only one particle left because
the universe has much more than 1
billion in one particle is a matter and
much more than 1 billion particles of
antimatter but I'm saying if that level
of imbalance persists throughout all of
space and applies to all of the
gargantuan numbers of particles of
matter and antimatter that are across
all the observable universe then the
amount of matter left over when the
matter and antimatter collide and
annihilate would be enough to yield the
stars and galaxies
what else all right already asked would
you rather time travel to the past or to
the future if you could only take a
one-way journey are already my view and
that is quite straightforward
I would absolutely prefer to travel to
the future which is a good thing because
time travel to the future is within the
laws of physics and time travel to the
past is likely not but why would I
rather travel to the future when I get
to the future I can read about the past
I can see videos about the past I can
whatever put on neural implants that
will allow me to learn about what
happened in the past the future is the
big mystery the future is the one that
we seem not to be able to learn about in
detail by sitting here at this present
moment and therefore the future holds
much more of an allure to me than the
past having said that as a human being
I'm not going to the future if I can't
take the people that make life worth
living I'm not going if my wife says no
I'm not going if my kids say no maybe
there are a few others I throw into that
group so I don't mean to exclude anybody
but yeah in terms of the distinction
between past and future to me it is the
future that holds the the greatest
attraction not the past can I explain a
bias about the delayed choice quantum
eraser and I can I'm actually going to
refer you I don't do this often but I'm
going to refer you to my book fabric of
the cosmos chapter 7 I'm sure you can
get a bootleg PDF version online I'm not
asking you to buy it and there I go
through great detail on the question
that you address so I'm going to leave
it at that because it would take me
pretty far afield to even set up how
that expired Nomad ask is there a
Heisenberg principle for thought
processes and look this is similar to a
question from before does the
uncertainty principle apply to thought
processes yes it does does it apply to
blue tea
and Swiss cheese it does because all
those things are made up of particles is
there something special about the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle as
applied to human thought as applied to
Swiss cheese or blue cheese I don't
think so
now could I be wrong about that could
quantum mechanics be more tightly
connected with conscious processes
people have suggested that serious
people have suggested that Eugene Wigner
one of the great minds of the last
centuries suggest to that at least for
one period of time I don't feel that way
I don't think mind is special in the
sense of having any other qualities
beyond particles and physical law
governing those particles and that's
exactly how I would describe cheese what
is special about the mind is that the
particles are highly arranged having
emerged from eons and eons of
evolutionary processes that's what's
special about the mind not that it deals
with quantum mechanics in some different
way but rather that it's highly
organized the pattern of the particles
is just exquisite compared to the
pattern of particles that make up a
chunk of cheese so in that sense yes
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
matters but no it doesn't play any
special role and that really is the key
thing to keep in mind
okay so Gabor asked as bomi mechanics of
any problems in replicating entanglement
and it does not and in fact bohmian
mechanics is in some sense an antidote
to the weirdness of entanglement as
described in the more conventional
quantum mechanical approach the
Copenhagen approach say Copenhagen
approaching tankmen totally weird
because particles really are in a
mixture of say up and down at the same
time so how in the world could measuring
a particle over here cause this particle
to snap out of the up-and-down that's
the spookiness that's the craziness
bohmian mechanics comes in and says
there's a very simple explanation
this particle when you measured it and
found up it was always up this particle
when you measured it and found it down
it was always down
nothing snapped out of a fuzzy haze
because there is no fuzzy haze in
bohmian mechanics and bohmian mechanics
that probabilistic nature emerges from a
different source it emerges from your
inability to understand the true
qualities of a particle but the particle
itself does have the qualities that
measurement reveals measurement doesn't
cause those properties to emerge
measurement simply reveals the
pre-existing properties that the
particles have so from that point of
view there is absolutely nothing strange
about entanglement in bohmian mechanics
all right so what did we do should we
wrap this up here
paradox as on you can find that in one
of the earlier episodes
I want to answer one good question and
then be done for today I keep saying
that I think I said that two hours ago
what form of matter Akash asked what
form of matter does a black hole consist
of and look in the traditional
description Akash
shal r of a black hole matter falls in
to a black hole that gets infinitely
squeezed what does that really mean
infinitely squeezed at the center and
there isn't really much happening
between say the center and the event
horizon of a black hole that's say been
hanging around for a long time so in
that sense a black hole kind of consists
of this singularity which as I said
earlier means we don't know what's going
on at the center empty space event
horizon which itself is empty space but
it does have a very important
implication that anything that folds
over the edge can't come out that's the
traditional classical description
quantum mechanically this story is more
involved people envision that maybe the
edge of a black hole is a firewall a
place of increasingly high temperature
anything that falls and gets incinerated
at the edge maybe there isn't even an
inside beyond the firewall my friend
Sameer Mathur maybe you guys know him as
I think there are I think there are a
few folks from India that are following
our discussion here Sameer Mathur is at
Ohio State of brilliant Indian physicist
I shared an office with him back in the
1980s and he came up with an idea that
black holes may actually really be in
some sense made of strings veteran that
are entangled with each other and what
he likes to call a fuzz ball and so a
black hole might actually be a fuzz ball
which mean the black holes not that
different from a star a star you know
you got this structure that burns on the
outside a fuzz ball could be a structure
that burns on the outside to it just as
an extreme version of that so we don't
really fully know the quantum mechanical
answered to the question of the deep
constituents of
a black hole so BOM dia says I'm in
Columbus Ohio fantastic you should go
look up Sameer tell him I said hi Oh
Traci day asks what are we having for
dinner
Traci day is my wife who has entered the
conversation with a very very deep
question which I suggest I suggest she
means I should probably wrap this up so
Traci day wife I think will have tofu
black bean sauce but I'm going to answer
one more question that just really wait
wait wait could this be it no it's not
wait I like this one
so John Faulkner asks about entanglement
I'd love to answer that but I've done so
much on entanglement John that I'm going
to do the rude thing and refer you to my
your daily equation episode on
entanglement which you can easily find
what else what else what else give me
that one question I'm looking for come
on there must be one year good someone
now talking to my wife Tracy that's nice
I appreciate that
so I'm going to end with with my friend
Ludwig von Beethoven you know a great
supporter of the series who asks how is
the proposal the time might be just an
illusion
compatible with the theory of relativity
and and you're right a little bit von
Beethoven there are people who say at
that time is an illusion and I will to
answer so so so there is a long history
of work that's been done I'm trying to
argue that the right way in the right
way to formulate physics and even the
right way to formulate the general
theory of relativity it's all about
relationships as opposed to there being
this drumbeat of time even if that
drumbeat is different for us depending
upon our motion and the gravity we
experience that the real fundamental
right way to formulate relativity would
not have time in those basic equations
the time itself would simply emerge from
those basic equations and there's some
evidence for that in string theory too
so I'm not suggesting that this is the
right way of doing physics or the wrong
way of doing because I'm merely noting
that there's a long history of people
developing that idea and and the reason
I raise that is because you can have
time emerge all of these approaches so
such that it has the qualities that we
experience in everyday life and it has
the experience that Einstein revealed
through special and the general theory
of relativity it could be the time is a
quality that is only relevant on say
certain length scales or certain
duration scales or in certain
environments and then fundamentally
there is no time written into the deeper
laws that we've yet to fully discover
that wouldn't mean that time is an
illusion that would mean that time is
emergent and and so I think that that's
the way that most of us think
about this possibility of there not
being any notion of time in the true
fundamental equations at that level I
guess time would be a loser II because
in those basic equations you wouldn't
see any conception of time but certainly
time as we experience it is real we all
experience it time as Einstein
articulated in relativity would be real
too
it just wouldn't be as fundamental so
there's a difference between something
being illusory and a mistake and
shouldn't be spoken of and something
being a loser e in the sense that it's
not fundamental that it's emergent so I
think emergent would be the better
language for discussing that notion of
time all right so I think that's more or
less it for today you should join us
on Monday for the next episode of your
daily equation again some of you asked
where episode 24 is and we'll get it out
maybe this weekend or maybe on Monday as
I noted early on the session I made a
small mistake a small mathematical
mistake in an episode I want to fix it
so we're just going to fix that and
we'll get it out to you
nothing conceptual is just a technical
thing I wrote an extra derivative I'm in
one equation so yeah I'm being perhaps a
little bit too persnickety to ensure
that that is done right but I'm going to
do that right and then on Monday or
Tuesday will pass into Einsteins ideas
of general relativity we did special
relativity and we'll talk about
curvature and gravity space-time
curvature and maybe we'll do some things
on black holes that would be quite
natural I'll turn to cosmology I want to
give you an understanding of the Big
Bang and inflationary cosmology and who
knows where we're gonna go from there if
at all maybe that would be a natural
winding down time for this series but
you know if you keep watching and keep
talking and keep asking I'm gonna still
be here so who knows maybe we'll keep on
going a little bit further into the
summer than I initially anticipated
you know life issues can sometimes get
in the way of that but I'm willing to
keep an open mind and listen to what you
guys would enjoy doing alright again if
you don't follow me on Twitter please do
in fact sometimes when I'm not doing an
episode of your daily equation I wish I
could just send out a tweet and reach
you guys because I kind of feel bad so
if if more of you would follow me it
would be an easier way for me to be in
touch with you guys
world science festival you should
subscribe I think there is a subscribe
button somewhere in this down there and
a lot of great content that's already on
the world science host website final
announcement before I go world science
you the educational arm of the world
science festival we are relaunching
really soon with a lot of really
interesting online courses that are all
free I have a full special relativity
course they're both with math and
without math we have courses that go
from cosmology all the way to issues of
consciousness so all for free you should
definitely check that out it'll be
available I think I think very soon I
think
April no or in May already so maybe
maybe it's in the next week or two so
keep your eyes out for that alright guys
thank you I've enjoyed this session with
you and looking forward to picking it up
live next Friday but we'll have our
usual doses of your daily equation
coming up this week all right
until then this is brian greene signing
off